un magic cube un bras robotique ou
encore une ferme verticale
quelques exemples parmi les 11 projets
industriels présentés par les étudiants
de l'école d'ingénieurs aisé au pari
vélizy c'est le cas de près si la bnsa
dit étudiant en 4e année en ingénierie
d'affaires elle a développé avec ses
camarades un projet autour de la
rénovation énergétique
notre projet a été de réaliser une
action de performance énergétique sont
l'ensemble de notre campus afin du coup
d'améliorer ses performances
premièrement il a été déjà important de
réaliser une audi du bâtiment par
exemple pourquoi pas installer de
nouvelles fenêtres qui s'adapterait du
coup à l'éblouissement du soleil ou des
radiateurs thermiques qui sont composés
de microprocesseurs et qui chauffera la
salle grâce à ses microprocesseurs
voilà plein d'action futuriste autre
projet avec 7 août six programmés pour
distribuer les médicaments à leur donner
à l'effigié est connecté à une
application donc sur cette application
on va rentrer le nom des médicaments
donc là on nous avons deux noms de
médicaments rentrée une fois connecté on
a juste besoin de ce que claude était au
bluetooth
une fois connecté ou qu'on peut faire
directement envoyées et les médicaments
seront sortis alors
souhaité le campus et 0 paris vélizy a
été créé en 2018
ces 230 élèves cette année répartis dans
quatre options le big data la
cybersécurité l'ingénierie et
l'intelligence artificielle 96 % des
étudiants connaissent une insertion
professionnelle à la sortie de l'école
objectif former de futurs ingénieurs et
même parfois de futurs entrepreneurs
avec un accompagnement spécifique
très concrètement alors fait une
présentation de comment déjà on pilote
la création d'une entreprise ou d'une
structure de l'idée première jusqu'à
l'étude de la viabilité et ses deux de
l'entreprise dont qu'ils ont une
personne référente sur le campus ici qui
peut les accompagner sur les différentes
étapes du projet et peut-être qu'un
futur entrepreneur se trouve parmi ces
onze projets présentés lors du premier
forum industriel de l'école aisé au pari
vélizy